The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT Open
CourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
We, we are solid
state devices.
This is soft matter.
My eyes are photo detectors.
Band gap of about two
electron volts.
They're just not made
of a compound
semiconductor inorganic.
And this motion is just
conformational
changes in a polymer.
See it's all chemistry.
The rest is stamp collecting.
So the principles that apply to
inanimate objects apply to
animate objects.
And the solid-state chemistry
umbrella is very broad.
If I say solid-state chemistry,
people are apt to
think of electronic devices,
transistors, what have you.
But that extends to
the life sciences.
I mean we, as human beings,
are chemical machines.
So this is the classical view.
Electronic structuring informs
bonding but then in 3.091
bonding informs atomic
arrangement, which tells you
everything.
The shape of all things, it's
all electronic structure.
There's nothing more.
The difference is that the
focus in the chemistry
department, their focus
is the molecule.
Whereas in 3.091 I like to
think of the focus being
aggregates of molecules,
namely solids.
Because engineering systems
are made of solids.
If you're steeped in chemistry
from high school, you've had
the AP curriculum, again 3.091
might be something that is a
fresh look at chemistry from
a slightly different
perspective.
What I wanted to play for you as
you're leaving today is an
old Beatles song, Lucy in
the Sky with Diamonds.
Being able to bring in subject
matter, music, art,
literature, into a chemistry
class and make the connections
to the world around us, I think
is most important in the
21st century, when problem
solving even in the technical
domain is going to require
skills that build bridges to
the humanities, arts and
social sciences.
And so I like to think of
3.091 not as a chemistry
class, but rather a
chemistry-centered class.
The majority of students taking
3.091 at MIT may never
take another chemistry class.
So I ask myself what topics are
critical for someone who
might major in electrical
engineering?
Or for someone who might
major in physics?
Or what's the chemistry that's
critical to an MIT student who
might major in political
science or economics?
And that informs my
choice of topics.
And it turns out that that
doesn't diminish from the
education of the student who
may choose to major in a
chemically intensive discipline
such as material
science, chemical engineering,
or even chemistry itself.
I don't view the presentation
of the subject matter as a
linear track, where this
is the beginning
and this is the end.
I view it more along the
lines of a spiral.
And so the first time you
encounter a certain concept
it's at a rather superficial
introductory level.
And then at some point later
in the semester you spiral
back and see it again.
And then maybe there's a little
more context and a
little more intensity.
Maybe there's a little
more mathematics
associated with it.
And then you'll see it
applied later again.
And through that revisiting--
repetition by design--
I think that key concepts
get driven home.
Some people are shocked that
I stand in front of a chalk
board and I write on it and I
believe that that's still a
valid means of teaching.
For the first-time learner
I think it's important to
activate all of the
learning channels.
The act of drawing
and inspiring
them to draw is important.
And maybe the person at home
ought to put themselves in a
chair in the auditorium and be
taking notes as though they
are attending the lecture.
Watching those videos,
especially for someone that
has had a fair bit of high
school chemistry, you're going
to hear a lot of the same things
but maybe coming at you
at a slightly elevated level.
But not so elevated that
you won't follow it.
And I think that's good for a
high school student to be
talked to at a higher level.
I think the videos also have
utility for people that are
interested in specific topics.
I mean for example, if somebody
needs to know
something about x-rays, or the
use of x-rays, dropping in to
that three-lecture sequence on
x-rays could be quite useful.
I think it's possible to
sample with a goal of
mastering a particular
concept.
So clearly for the learner out
in the World Wide Web, going
to recitation and interacting
with a recitation instructor
is not practical.
So in lieu of the recitation
section OCW has created these
help session videos.
We actually hired some
recitation instructors from
the fall of 2009 and asked
them to work through some
sample problems and what you see
in the help session video
is essentially what would
have happened in
a recitation section.
I issue the homework questions
with model solutions at the
beginning of the unit.
So the homework becomes
a study aid.
And I recommend to students
that they try the homework
problems without referring to
the answer key initially.
And to turn to the answer key
when they reach an impediment.
What's the message of 3.091
for the man on the street?
An understanding of those
relationships.
Electronic structure
to bonding.
Bonding to atomic arrangement.
Atomic arrangement
to properties.
Is the key to understanding
the world around us.
And in particular it's the
key to fueling invention.
And I believe in practice very
much and in the application of
science in service
for humanity.
Why do we worry about designing
a car that's a
zero-emission vehicle, as
if to do no harm to the
environment?
Why don't we go even further and
say, what about a car that
purifies the air as it
drives down the road?
So that the air in the wake of
the car is cleaner than the
air in front of the car?
And I'm finding that
increasingly that's a message
that resonates with
the students.
They want to take the tools
of technical analytically
centered education and
put them to work to
solve societal problems.